el primer vuelo que transportaba a
solicitantes de asilo a ruanda desde
reino unido se queda en tierra así lo
anunció antes de la medianoche la ong
care for kale este martes el gobierno
británico pretendía cumplir con sus
amenazas y enviar a siete refugiados
desde londres a kigali la capital
ruandesa al tribunal europeo de derechos
humanos emitió una medida cautelar
urgente para bloquear las deportaciones
forzosas de estos solicitantes de asilo
a pesar de los desafíos legales el
primer ministro británico boris johnson
reiteró su intención de continuar con su
política antimigratoria
esta es una parte fundamental de nuestra
estrategia para acabar con el modelo de
negocio de estas personas estos
traficantes que comercian con la
angustia y la gente suele pagar con su
vida estándar lloyd se estima que desde
inicios de año unos diez mil migrantes
han cruzado el canal de la mancha para
llegar al suelo británico pero la medida
de johnson para frenar este flujo
migratorio ha generado fuertes críticas
entre las organizaciones humanitarias
que denuncian un trato inhumano y una
política inmoral puesto que el gobierno
ruandés ha sido acusado por las ongs de
reprimir libertades de sus ciudadanos
además muchos de estos solicitantes de
asilo no tienen ningún vínculo con el
país
y enviar a un país que no respeta los
derechos humanos es una forma de
evolución para las personas que se
arriesgan a ser perseguidas el fútbol es
diferente al de tu persona el que
distintos ciclos y el gobierno de
johnson argumentó que su política
pretende luchar contra las mafias que
transportan migrantes actuales del canal
mientras del otro lado cientos de
personas esperan poder llegar a la isla
en busca de una vida más digna